- Hello, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
- We're the Slow Mo Guys.
- Gav, I was in the Army
for about seven years--
- Yeah, you were Dan.
- Which means that I've
got a lot of experience
in firing different types of guns,
and just before we did
the "Super-Slow Show",
we fired possibly the
fattest kind there is.
Big .50 cal rifle.
- We shot the mirror right in the face.
- We did.
We did.
- And the rounds were about this big.
- Yeah, I got a headache from firing it
a few too many times.
- Well, you've clearly read the title.
You know this video is
the complete opposite.
- Bit of a giveaway!
- This is a tiny little pinfire gun,
which technically isn't a firearm,
because it's not rimfire, it's pinfire.
It's got a little keyring on it.
- Oh, you can have it as a key ring!
- Yeah, you could wear it as a necklace.
- Wow, so the 50 cal is 12.7 mil, I think,
and that's two mil, which
is a hefty difference.
- It's wee.
- Look, there's like 20 rounds in here.
It's a tiny little bottle.
Look at this little bottle!
Most bullets are bigger than this.
- [Gav] You know what,
we're not doing a very
good size comparison.
We don't have a standard
procedure American quarter.
There you go.
Georgie Wash.
- Oh, nice one!
That's crazy, isn't it?
I've got sweaty hands, so this
is gonna be so hard to do.
- Nice.
- Slipped in there.
- Slips right in.
- No safety,
but I'm not gonna cock it yet,
I'm just gonna put it there.
That's ready to fire now.
You hit that with anything
else, it'd just blow it away.
- [Gav] It would absolutely annihilate it.
- It'd just annihilate it,
you'd never see it again.
- [Gav] Right, what do you
think you're aiming for?
I reckon a middle A.
- Middle A?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
I'm a bit nervous,
because I've never missed
from this far before.
So if I miss --
- But when you think about
it, when you scale it up,
it's further.
- It's like a 25-meter shot.
- [Gav] Yeah.
- Ready?
- Mm-hmm .
- It's a hit!
- You got it?
- I got it!
- Ooh, smells nice.
- Ooh, it makes a dent as well.
- You didn't get A, you got C.
- Are you complaining about me missing?
Look at this, right?
Look at the sheen on my fingers, yeah?
I have to pull this back,
and then I have to like
fire this with my nail,
and my sweaty palms.
It's like slipping all over the place.
It's a wonder I can even
fire the damn thing!
It must mean it's quite
powerful if I hit it
at such a low center of gravity,
and it still knocked the target over.
Whoa, wow!
Gosh!
- It flattened it.
- [Dan] That flattened
it, 'cause that's a ball!
- Okay, so let's go frame by frame,
and see if we need to go faster.
Seems like it fires a lot of gumph.
- [Dan] Yeah, in that tiny
little round, it's like--
- [Gav] Oh, there, there it is,
you can see it streak to the front
of all those sparks there.
- [Dan] I saw it, it was
in the middle of the smoke
when it came out, and
now it's overtaken it.
- Oh, wow, so it's still
a streak at 12,500 FPS!
- God, that's mental!
- That is really fast!
I wonder what the, like,
foot-per-second of that thing is.
'Cause that was a, you said it was a blur.
- [Dan] You just have to
crack the barrel like this,
and then in there, in the
end, is our spent round.
So we've got to get our push rod here,
shove it in, and it should
just push out the old round.
There we go, that's the push rod there.
You see, it's got all like
black carbon around it,
'cause it's been fired,
and it doesn't have a bullet on it there,
whereas these ones, let's just
open our little magazine up.
Boop, these ones are clean,
and they have little
ball bullets on the end.
You can see the difference there.
I want one now, as like a little
necklace or like a keyring.
That'd be so cool!
- [Gav] Yeah, someone
walks up to you and goes,
"Hey, mate, do you carry?"
- Yeah, I've got an open
carry license actually.
There we go!
We've moved further back,
there's a couple of feet here,
and I'm gonna try and
burst a Strawberry Soda,
red sort-of fizzy drink can.
- [Gav] I've gone all the way over here,
because I don't wanna get
sticky on the cameras.
- Bit harder to hit the target
from here actually, as well.
- Is it?
- Yeah.
It's killing me!
- [Gav] No way!
- It got me directly in the face!
- Oh man, if I hadn't had these on,
it'd have got me in the eye ball!
- It came out the other side!
- Did it?
I'm not getting shot by that thing!
- [Gav] It went all the way through!
- That's the entrance there.
- Did you go right
through the hole in the E?
- [Dan] Yeah well that's what
I was aiming for, obviously.
- [Gav] Yeah, I looked
over and it was just,
it was spewing out of both sides at once.
- Right, this is what I saw, okay?
I was here, just like, "Fire, come on!"
After aiming, it fired, and I
was surprised that it fired,
and then, 'cause I had my eyes open,
all I saw was this, I saw
in slow motion, I swear,
just strawberries coming
straight at my face.
I don't even think it hit the table.
It just went, , straight into my eyes,
and on my ears, and everything,
and I was just like, .
Absolutely nailed me!
That's incredible!
I was never expecting it
to go through both sides,
I thought it would sort of
struggle to get through one side.
And this is what I mean, right?
It just went straight to me!
- Just straight in your face!
- [Dan] It didn't even hit the table!
It's not even hitting the table,
it just went straight into my face.
- That's so funny!
- That's perfect.
- You've drunk half the can.
- Yeah, I really have.
What a way to open a can!
I think it's the only gun
that's actually comical.
It's funny how small it is,
and it even made a
cheeky little exit there,
just tore through, I've
never seen such a small hole!
God!
- It knocked it over!
- Jeez!
So you would assume that
this is the exit wound,
but, if you push it together,
you can actually see that
that's where it went in,
and it's come out of here.
Ooh, just took off, the
entire can took off!
- [Gav] When the pellet
comes out the other side,
it doesn't split immediately.
There's actually a few frames
where it's just a hole.
- [Dan] That's because
this is pressurized,
so as soon as it like gets weakened,
it just goes, grunts.
- [Gav] What are you about to do?
- Shoot a little Lego man
in the face with this.
This to him, is gigantic!
- [Gav] It's like an artillery cannon!
- Yeah, it's like an
artillery cannon or something.
Okay, ready?
- Yep.
Oh, where'd he go?
- [Gav] He just vanished!
- Where'd he go?
Oh here he is, I found him!
Oh his arm went!
I took his arm off!
I took his arm off.
- [Gav] At this speed,
when I rock it backwards
and forwards, you can
actually see the momentum
travel through his body like
he's a full-sized human.
- [Dan] Look, you can
see where it's hit there,
and it's like, knocked his arm off.
- He's got an arm off.
- I'm sorry pal!
- [Gav] So this bloke has
survived a Lego plane crash.
- Yeah.
- And now you blew his arm off?
- I feel sorry for him now,
you've made me feel guilty about it.
There's no need for that!
I think I got him.
Think I knocked his block off.
I shot his hat off!
- [Gav] You shot the hat off a Lego man?
- Yeah.
- [Gav] I think it hit
the front of his hat.
See that dent in his red hat?
- [Dan] Yeah, that's an
absolute headshot there.
- [Gav] It protected him!
- [Dan] His earphones
are still on as well.
- His muffs and his hat protected him.
It actually saved his head!
- [Dan] So found his hat.
It's got a huge dent in it
right in the forehead middle part.
To scale that's probably about
a mile that his hat flew.
This is an execution.
Oh wow.
- Ah, hit my finger!
- It hit you!
Because this is so small,
I wanna get a shot on a macro lens.
This is a Canon macro lens,
and this is a PL mount,
so I'm gonna have to do a
little bit of open-heart surgery
on the Phantom here.
First I should take this lens off.
You tilt it down a little bit,
sort of lessens the chance
that anything will fall onto the sensor.
Canon mount,
stick a shim in there.
- [Dan] I like how you're
individually tightening the screws
a little bit, because it's
a circle you can't get away
with just tightening one at a time.
- Yeah, if you put one all the way in,
then there's no way this one would go in.
So now this Phantom fits Canon lenses!
Get a look at the end of
that, isn't that weird?
- [Dan] Tiny.
Nice job!
- Thank you!
- We're gonna use the clamp
just to make sure that
because of the macro
has such a fine little focus,
and I've got such fat fingers,
anytime I fire it,
it inevitably moves
millimeters left and right,
but because we're macro that means that
that's a whole world out of focus.
So we're gonna have to use
a clamp here to make sure
it just doesn't move, and
I'll just, boop, fire it.
All right.
Oh my word, it makes it look huge!
Ooh!
- Look at this, it looks so big and heavy.
It's like, .
- [Dan] It looks like a huge
piece of machinery, doesn't it?
- Yeah, just the fact that
the legs sink into the grass,
was throwing the whole thing out of focus.
I was having to hold it in 3D space.
- I saw you bracing
your thumb against this.
- I was doing this.
I was like, I was
controlling the whole thing
by extending my finger
against the table, like that.
- Yeah, it's clever!
- [Gav] So this will be a
macro shot right at the barrel.
- [Dan] Firing.
Ooh!
It's so quick, you don't see anything.
- You don't see anything.
Just for size comparison
in that macro shot,
I wanna see what the coin
looks like next to the barrel.
Go for it!
- That is mental!
- [Gav] A good visual comparison there.
- That is really cool, nice idea!
I like how the foresight is out of focus,
but the side of the barrel isn't.
That must be like a millimeter?
Yeah, a quarter is
fatter than the distance
between the foresight and
the edge of the barrel,
which is like, about
a millimeter probably.
So one mil out, and you've
completely lost focus.
Is it weird that I had as much
fun firing this little thing
as I did the 50 cal,
just in a different way?
- I prefer this because
it doesn't rattle my head.
- Well, of course you do!
Yeah, to be fair, I have a
headache after firing this now.
Yeah, that's really little, really fun.
- I might though, on the macro shots,
take all the sounds from
the 50 Cal and put 'em.
I liked that though,
just enjoyed the whole
of making that video.
Just nice and fun, nice and easy.
Aside from the macro,
that was a nightmare.
- Surprisingly powerful though.
Have to be careful with these things.
They're not to be messed
around with, really.
- Well I mean we saw
what it did to the can,
it had an exit wound.
- Exactly, exactly, yeah.
- You wouldn't want that
in your eye or any skin.
- No, so just point it away at all times,
you're wearing like safety
goggles, and all that good stuff.
My trigger discipline was solid today.
- Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to follow us on Instagram,
subscribe to our YouTube
channel, that's this one.
We've also got the other one
behind the scenes and all that,
Slow Mo Guys 2.
You can bung that a sub
as well if you want.
It's just more us, tragically, just,
just more of us blokes, we'll
see you in the next video!